For this assignment, talk about how you might use notion of recording cases to
design an agent that can solve Raven's Progressive Matrices. You might think of
cases in a variety of different ways here. For example, each figure in
a problem could be a case. Each transformation between figures could be a case.
Or more broadly, each problem that your agent has encountered in
the past could be a case. As part of this, you'll also need to
think about how to evaluate similarity. If you're using figures,
how do you evaluate the similarity between two figures in a problem?
Or how do you evaluate the similarity between two transformations and a problem?
Or more broadly, how do you find what problem that you face in the past,
is most similar to the new one you're facing now?